Community Pride on 8 news now is
sponsored by Our Community Pride
Partners Finley Automotive Group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care and
Silver State Schools Credit Union
Findlay automotive group the sponsors of
this segment have all hands on deck for
Three Square Food Bank especially during
the holidays Rocky stopped by three
Square's headquarters to learn how you
can help too
Findlay automotive is determined to keep
three squares Food Bank rich in meals
and hands this is one of Findlay
automotive's favorite Charities we uh we
you know support them financially but we
also have volunteers we've had a lot of
volunteers come out here and and help
the package up food for people but it's
a great charity there's tons of hungry
people in Nevada and three squares here
to deal with that and that's why we love
this charity and although Findlay
supports all year round Kate Hibbert of
Three Square says joining forces during
the holiday season is extra significant
right now is a really great time to give
back we have our holiday match going on
right now typically for every dollar
donated you can provide three meals back
to into the community when donating to
Three Square but right now with this
match every dollar can provide up to six
meals which is really phenomenal and if
you can't donate money you can donate
time you can work in our kitchen you can
work in our warehouse packing produce or
packing After School meals all kinds of
opportunities yeah our you know when our
employees come out here they just love
volunteering they get a sense of worth
and doing something good for the
community so that's a great way for
people to get involved so let's take a
tour of the facility the food is fresh
and the people are bustling
[Music]
behind us is our North Campus Warehouse
where we have a group of Volunteers in
today we rely on volunteers to make our
work happen every single day here at
three Square anybody age 10 and up with
a parent can come out and volunteer we
offer volunteer opportunities Monday
through Friday and again we just really
rely on that Community Support we cannot
do this work without our volunteers
they're such a vital part of our efforts
so a lot of volunteers here at the
holidays but you probably need them at
other times of the year too right yeah
you know everybody thinks about
volunteering at the holiday time and
want to give back which is great but you
know if I can give a little plug we
really need help in January and February
everyone goes back to work school's back
in session and sometimes people forget
that there's still a need out there in
this community the unfortunate reality
is that one out of seven of our
neighbors doesn't always know where
their next meal is coming from one out
of four children go home to a food and
secure household and with the holiday
match program the Southern Nevada
Community can change that let's go back
and talk just a little bit about the
match program because it's a great time
for people to donate yeah it really is a
great time to donate right now through
the end of the year through November
31st every dollar that's donated can
provide six meals thanks to our
corporate sponsors and so what a great
time to maximize your donation have a
great impact throughout this community
and help those who might not have enough
food this holiday season
we want to thank Findlay automotive
group for being one of our Community
Pride Partners Las Vegas now we'll be
ready